solange es besser aussieht als lucas
solange es besser aussieht als lenas
halbe wand da
also jetzt ein echter sehen oder spar
kaufrecht auch wirklich so heißt du mich
auch darum wie facebook denkt doch jeder
naja bei facebook als auch der natürlich
klar besser zusammen geschrieben dass
mein künstlername stehe darum passt
natürlich mit kaputter sehr geehrter
sprach kopf da ist dann doch nicht es
ist echt heftig wenn man dann noch die
ruhe bewahren muss bei solchen fragen
bei solchen schrecklichen fragen welche
die skepsis texture pack eine
beschreibung der flagship er so ich habe
heute noch ich krieg mittlerweile
heftige nachrichten so was wie das war's
mag der eine gott als überschrift und
dann jahr für so viel gelernt blablabla
fanclub gegründet und wir sind bereit
für dich du sterben service ging es ab
wo mein golf fans hast aber die wollen
sie haben
nein also ja irgendwie was ich fanclub
gegründet
ich wäre der geilste überhaupt und dass
das ja auch sie bereit wären für mich zu
stemmen
ich hab das schon mal nebenbei
angesprochen gehabt aber das war echt so
richtig klasse nachricht ich hab mir auf
facebook aus natürlich nahm zensiert
oder ausgestattetes klar kann ich nicht
machen aber da kommen jetzt echt heftig
ins zeug bei mir rein würden oder andere
hat fatih behörde hat sich mein logo auf
dem t shirt gedruckt oder willst dich
drucken lassen und er hat nachts
geträumt ihr würdet mir ein lp machen
ausgeträumt ok ich glaube in denen wir
auch so einen coolen weg von uns von
meinem zu eurem haus machen ja also von
meinem zustand weil man einfach den weg
von koch media klauen
ich habe gerade vor den schönen weg
gefunden den er voll die ich habe in der
letzten folge so wasser der übrigens
neues thema
das thema dann habe ich in den letzten
aufnahmen richtig coole ich habe die
natur gerettet und einflüsse miteinander
verbundenen nächstes jahr in kuba ich
könnte hier rausholen creator mir muss
gleich alle schlechten licht da kommt
immer noch die elz park wo fühlst du
dich jetzt genau wie bauen er so in
meine richtung oder er dabei pop shop
media ahnung vielleicht als andere ende
der welt ich muss man gucken wo platz
ist weit weit weg
far away oder crack muss man einfach
kennen das wasser quell schreck aus dem
track zu tun
far far away zurückzuschrecken luca
sagst doch gleich hätten das programm of
the track wechseln könnte und track club
einblenden kann minecraft das ist ja sie
müssen mich aufklären eingeschränkt ist
doch dieses diese anwendung uns allen ja
genau
und da über dieses land von den highway
frech ist werte wirklich
wir hatten aber hat james park das mag
sein aber das kommt mit sicherheit nicht
daher davon wo hast du denn ich habe
einfach gesagt fahr ganz allgemeine
sache ich dachte erst es wäre speziell
auf aufschreckt bezogen
nein wir komplett vorbei gerichtet alter
ich bin hier schon anderthalb 6 am level
up farben jetzt weg ins neues thema so
jetzt ganz schnell thema vorschlag von
harm spvgg
die minecraft entwicklungen in richtung
rpg sie seht ihr dass man hier so immer
mehr tränke sich darüber tausenden
zutaten zusammengebraut und verzaubern
und so weiter und level sammeln und
statt dem führenden genossen bauen
ehrlich gesagt alten version spielen ja
genau man muss eigentlich immer mal
sagen wer die leute die sich beschweren
können
auf einer alten version spieler gibt es
mittlerweile überall jahr download sind
ich glaube es gibt und welche programme
wo man sich das dann zurück patchen kann
aber als noch alle genres afe 21.5 punkt
eins also ich kann auf 1.5 zurück
patchen theoretisch also aber ich finde
dass minecraft allgemein damit ich habe
da getrennt meinung natürlich müssen die
neuen neuen neuen content bringen damit
die fans denken okay dann spielt doch
mal wieder minecraft wenn ein paar neue
coole sachen zugekommen sind aber ich
ehrlich gesagt halte davon nicht so viel
also ich finde es nicht so toll ich
stehe auch nicht so auf rollenspiele
aber ich finde es jetzt nicht so gut
dass man mit 10 milliarden tränke und da
stehe ich überhaupt gar nicht mehr durch
und so das ist einfach nicht mehr
minecraft ich mein früher hat man
angefangen in der beta das war wirklich
simpel blöcke einfach nur blöcke nennig
und mittlerweile ist das echt ja dann
trank und verzaubert hat es ist schon
echt heftig geworden - außer ich steckte
auch nicht mehr so wirklich durch also
früher hatte ich echt einen überblick
über alle sachen design minecraft gab
und jetzt mittlerweile mit denen ich
wüsste keinen einzigen trank jetzt aus
dem kopf der wie man die macht was mich
so ein bisschen aufregt ist dass die
reds und schaltung teilweise geändert
werden müssen das heißt funktioniert so
wie früher als jetzt alles auf servern
stattfindet das minecraft auf den
singleplayer ein bisschen lady meistens
und funktion mein gestaltung nicht muss
irgendwo größere verzögerungen
einstellen verstehen sondern die folge
klappen funktionieren von nicht mehr als
was gebaut das ganze branche laufen
schmeißen
heute hast du dich noch heute das erste
mal wieder getrübt zum thema
wechselseitige klopp zum beispiel hat
vorher einwandfrei funktioniert hat
schon zwei andere tutorials gebraucht
gehabt wie jetzt geht es nicht mehr es
muss das ding immer komplett optimieren
und so ein bisschen was neue mit
reinbringen
mit dem kontinuierlichen blog update
sache durch kein war es aber egal was
blog update wer das pro sekunde da
wieder im blog update durchgeführt wird
damit die ganze maschinerie noch läuft
na ja also ich finde es allgemein cool
dass so viele leute da ich weiß nicht
hast du schon selber irgendwas in
minecraft erfunden soll redstone
technisch oder nur ich hatte mal ganz
ursprünglich so eine art loswerden das
heißt lustig klopp mit die erste klopp
mit pisten glaube ich erfunden nur nicht
recht bedenkt das war schon als die
piste noch eingeführt wurde durch zufall
ich wollte ein heim für bauen auf einer
bahre ein kabel eingeklemmten der türen
das hat
ganze zeit wiederholt also auf zu
aufzuweisen jetzt müssen wir gucken dann
ist es so eine art klopp damals kann man
nur so five klopp zum beispiel also
austritts von fackeln und noch andere
mechanismen also mit repeatern dort wo
das im kreis läuft aber sondern sich mit
fristen gab es noch gar keine clogs also
ich hab das halt motor getauft weil das
so lustig außerdem pisten er sich ganz
aus den wieder einzieht
ich glaube das war so ja mein beitrag
zur reaktion welt aber ist nichts
besonderes in dem fall ja ich finde
eigentlich wirklich extrem geil was ich
da leute aus denken also ich denke
eigentlich nur ein set play den ihr
eigentlich alle kennen solltet oder also
könnt ihr auch soja setzt bankings
häftling aber zu israel sagst du hörst
den kindern auch nicht ich kenne es
pläne den anderen eigentlich nicht egal
jedenfalls ich finde schon krass was die
da alles leisten aber ich finde auch
sowas natürlich ist es extrem geil aber
ich finde sowas ist auch nicht mehr mein
kreis soest in dem sinne von einfach
eine schaltung so was wir finden von
system- oder soja doch da habe ich schon
das einheitlich mal nicht so in die mini
games oder sowas
achso mini die augen als ich sag mal von
von einfach bis problem eine lösung sagt
man form von der schaltung mit dem sagt
jetzt hier ganz und boden ist halt ein
loch drin also einfach ein lava
beckenboden sonst nix und auf einmal
drückst und klopfen
die lava geht auf dass es durch den
nahen fluss reinspringen kann ist
irgendwie so eine art pisten mechanismus
was soll ich zum beispiel auch schon
gebastelt
ich habe vorher noch mal gesehen wie es
im groben aussehen können am ende aber
ohne lösungen ist selbst
zusammengebastelt dann auch ein bisschen
anders als der typ dann oder so und noch
viele andere sachen auch eigentlich mein
so ungefähr 50 sommer 30 40 50 prozent
um den dreh von der tollste habe ich
dann selbst gebaut und erfunden sei
jetzt machen aber ich finde für mich
alles ist das wirklich kein minecraft
mehr also wenn die leute zuschauer hier
gerade dieses video hier sehen ist ja
schon das los let's play draußen wo ich
in der minecraft beta 1.5 hardcore
spiele und ich muss echt sagen dass es
extrem geil mal wieder so man hat so ein
komplettes nostalgie gefühl weil man
dann einfach wieder dieser alten welt
ist man hört diese alte musik da sie
noch total andere lichtverhältnisse die
travel textur ist noch richtig hammer so
wirklich komplett ohne texture pack das
ist schon eigentlich alles extrem geil
jetzt erst mal so richtig blöde
von wegen man hatte noch gar nicht hier
tolle shader und alles aber keine ahnung
wie brauche ich das gar nicht ich will
einfach nur simpel blöcke das ist
minecraft und ich habe dafür da ist
längst keine merkwürdigen konstrukte in
der wüste die ich gerade gefunden habe
hast du interessierst du deine haben
brunnen gefunden nach brunnen das geht
ja es gibt auch richtige wüstenfestival
gibt's auch steckt die kisten mal ist
und auch für harte kurs ich hab was
cooles gefolgt auch ein brunnen brawn
ich bin als ob heim aber ich muss was
essen
es passt genau das eine halbe stunde um
dich irgendwie hin zu bauen hast du
glaub schon dass ich hab noch gar nicht
angefangen ich hab's mal material
gesammelt hast du schon planen
ich habe schon plan ja ja ja ich habe ja
klar ich hab immer umplanen weißt du so
lange es besser aussieht als lukas ic
waggons olang jetzt besser aussieht als
die halbe wand da hat er mich nicht
jeder vor bauen also ich bin kein großes
häuschen bauen einfach so ein kleines
häuschen gemütlich noch etwas anbauen
weil die vor deiner vor deiner tür ist
also ein riesen fläche frei du da kommt
aber erst mal meine farm hin dass hinter
allen klar bei dir ist gedacht da wo ich
stehe
wollt ihr deswegen habe ich das extra so
frei gemacht kaseya hierhin bauen hier
noch platz genau da unten da unten ist
extrem viel platz hier so ihnen wo da wo
ich hingucke achter schickt ihr schon
was man auf da hier das reicht es reicht
ok cool einfach der reiz des rechts ihr
rechts einfach noch ein bisschen in
unserer nähe
genau jene kuscheligen verbindungsweg
okay aber schön ja mach ich für morgen
gleich wieder wenn ich dann auf den weg
nach hause finden eine offenstehende
einen wieder hin dass amazon brunnen
noch ein grund was ist denn da sind da
in die items oder so ich finde egal ist
wie viele brunnen sind hier bitte
nur ein dorf ein dorf treiben und eine
festung eine festung
mein gott das ist eine festung tempel
oder wüsten tempel gehöre jetzt ein zum
größten serena koordinaten 314 und 800
der fahrstunde chf 14 800 ist aber weit
weg du ohne schein läuft gleich auf
jeden fall darauf diese platten messe
noch da unten im tempel klassischen
platten was den platten
gleich drauf hast mir waren verdammt der
wieder drauf laufen
never ever der sich freut sich der
unterbau oder valentina harth
das ist nur eine nervosität zu
überdenken länder talent and a wollt ihr
mal wieder aufnehmen wenn das anstehen
ausländer waren was ich von euch gesehen
ich weiß kann man sowieso so furcht
einflößen hier in heller alter spielt
selber bevor wir mussten acht spielen
liegt oberhalb angetrunken
dann wirst du schon merken was daran so
schlimm ist okay luca der alkoholiker
man man man also ich hab dazu gesehen
weil sie so geschrien aber so gedacht
sondern eine augenbraue hoch gezogen
ja du bist einfach der coolste party
wissen was mit cool sein zutun
na ja nur als das davor und hat mir
zugedacht hören waren durch schlimme ich
hätte das locker abgekommen da spielt
man einfach mitten in haft sind wir dann
im video antwort dann werden wir sehen
ok
change accepted was wär doch was für
zwei kanal oder ein gaming kanal hab ich
ja auch die meine ich damit dritt kanal
führt kanal
das reicht so hoch kanal bei allgemein
so einfach nur sich nebenbei konrad 30
granada er muss jetzt oder assets play
gibt von allen anderen spielen außer
minecraft ich finde es wichtig dass man
das ein bisschen trend sind mit erneut
ist ein kanal abonniert weil die ideen
so haben wollen wir jetzt ist dann
kannst du schlecht was anderes daraus
machen ein paar leute eigentlich hast du
dein zweiter kanal nur gemacht und
darauf kontrast das lagerfeuer lied
hochzuladen hauptkanal hochgeladen weil
es so lustig war es mehr leute ist
doppelt peinlich weißt du was ich
gefunden habe würden gold bau und bones
was albarn graham andrew hasborn spot
gold rotten flesh bei uns bei uns ans
herz legen falle locken bei uns bei uns
komplett dahin gelaufen
das tnt kaputt gemachte kurz es geht
hoch früher ist das hochgegangen alten
mine konversionen womit wir wieder beim
thema werden
ich habe jetzt sogar wo ich kann meine
tnt kanone bauen
tnt carbon edition ja früher schon
gemacht
in der letzten höher ohne mich zu war
auf einmal fliegt mit außenluft
ich hab jetzt schon so einen schönen weg
gebaut
ich bringe diese hieroglyphen seiner
sense somit macht das die sache gegangen
ganz viele fans damit ich brauche auch
noch welche aha dann müssen wir traden
was kannst du mir anbieten sowie trade
ich kann dir anbieten über ich schon er
sich so village geraten hatte was hast
du village erraten er genau ich gebe
jetzt weiß maracle dafür gibst du mir
bitte 1 enstone
ja okay für zwei mark damit ihr song an
ich habe noch kein einziges markt
gefunden